hey guys welcome back to brand new video
we're back on for honor again and today
is gonna be
the executions for year four season two
and usually when i do these sorts of
videos i play each faction separately so
i do the knights and the vikings on the
samurai then the wool in
but today i'm going to be flip-flopping
every different character is going to be
shown you know different factions stuff
to kind of alternate a bit
because these are actually faction based
usually we get hero based meaning when
centurion does an execution
there isn't one that is the exact same
within the season
all of the knights have the same
execution all the vikings have the same
execution all the samurai and all of the
woolen have the same execution
of course within their own faction they
all don't have the same thing as
you'll see within the video so i'll be
playing it for every specific character
just in case you want to see what it
looks like with your character
specifically
but yeah that's really about it honestly
i kind of saw this coming with all the
stuff that's been happening recently
with the pandemic and stuff they don't
really have a lot of time to mocap a
bunch of different
executions for every single character so
i understand doing faction based this
time and honestly
these are pretty damn cool so i'm
totally cool with what we have with this
season of executions
either way let me know your favorite
executions in the comments down below
with that take care guys have a great
yesterday and peace out
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so